in the beginning I was just thrilled to
note that someone was asking me to be in
a movie and I thought that was all that
was required and as long as they keep
asking everything everything will fall
fall into place when somebody laughs at
Shakespeare in high school you're done
man you're just you're just settled it's
that's all you want to do from then on
it's hard to get past that that the
realization that you're you're
pretending to be somebody and people are
looking at if faith is cultivated it
will achieve mastery he's an American
actor and filmmaker his films have
grossed over four point three billion
dollars in US and Canada and over eight
point five billion dollars worldwide
he's been nominated for numerous acting
awards during his career he's Tom Hanks
and here's my take on his top ten roles
for success rule number ten is my
personal favorite and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end for some
special bonus clips and as a hear Tom
talk if he says something that really
inspires you make sure to write it down
in the comments below and put quotes
around it so other people can learn and
be inspired as well in the beginning I
was just thrilled to know that someone
was asking me to be in a movie and I
thought that was all that was required
and as long as they keep asking
everything everything will fall fall
into place mm-hmm and I think I had to
become dissatisfied with my own process
you know five or six movies in where I
was feeling that that I was not I was
not bringing I was not bringing to the
work anything other than that anything
other than that instinct and that's when
I realized that you know okay I'm part
of me got older and I think even if
you're as old as 29 you you have a
different set of chops and perspective
you have a different believe-it-or-not
wisdom that you did when you were 24 and
I think about every five years I went
through some sort of process of
reexamining where I was in life you know
as a man as well as an actor and
thinking like guess what I'm 36 now and
there's a whole world of movies that I
can't make anymore because I can no
longer I don't want to play the young
man who's trying to figure out life I
want to play a man of bitter
remise I want to play somebody who's
who's been through something so it's a
never-ending process I think of
examining where you are in life as a
human being and then transposing that so
it's going to be reflected in your work
somehow well this is interesting this is
a very important show business lesson
and this is why I always come Gary all I
am is an instinctive actor I don't know
how to do anything else all right this
is another story about repetition and
learning by doing we we did Twelfth
Night in in high school I was playing
Andrew aguecheek and that not Fabian
Fabian is a bad role I might have been
cut from my heel I was playing ed you
area Andrew aguecheek and we had done it
like most high schools you know do it
what ho I chose you what moment did we
all sounded like that except John Gill
christen who was a great actor
and we one day we were told by our drama
teacher that we were going to perform
scenes at every assembly for the day so
we performed these scenes three times in
six times in one day we didn't have to
go to class we just had to perform these
these scenes from Shakespeare for about
300 people at a time 300 of our friends
and or enemies or the people that we you
know hope we wouldn't see at school we
would show up because they were evil but
and so about third assembly well we
started cutting up and by the time we
got to the sixth one I had five or six
gags a surrender a Agrotech that were
absolute killer and with you know when
somebody laughs at Shakespeare in high
school you're done man you're just
you're just settled it's that's all you
want to do from then on yeah I was I was
a worthless student anyway but that made
me even more so we want you to play a
guy called Alan whose marriage is in
bits so he goes to Saudi Arabia to try
and sell the King some high-tech virtual
reality at what point do you say I mean
I'm in it right about the time that all
of the major studios say no way in hell
we make this movie that dude when they
where they are so against the idea make
the movie and you know you're going to
be you know you've got something can you
make a movie like this that has the
significance it is and everybody's
talking about there's a buzz about it at
the same time you're working with a
great director with their track work
that you've had it's been three years
since you've made a movie do you learn
something from this experience you learn
yeah you learned at the inn to trust
your instincts more than anything else
because you can't ultimately it's not
it's not an intellectual process we're
acting or making making a movie in it
for specifically acting at a movie there
is a way early on in the early on you
make this judgment decision yes I'll do
it yes no I won't that's that's really a
after that you just have to fill
yourself up make yourself this kind of
repository thing you can't six months
prior to it be redoing some reason you
see this moment right here I am going to
utilize that moment with a time and no
it has to be some other you just keep
loading yourself up so that when the
moment comes you have so much the
intangible stuff that you're at your
fingertips so that you can realize oh I
know I have nine images in my head that
will help me communicate this idea as
opposed to one specific decision I made
six months ago or even the night before
and I remember reading that you said
after league of their own and that
wonderful character you know what I
don't think I want to play [ __ ] I can
play [ __ ] anymore anything that now I
don't need [ __ ] in the oh I know in
the bad term the peninsula the
pejorative sense well actually it is but
it's not in the nasties so you mean guys
who have are out of can't have any
control over their over their desk again
why is this happening to me yeah I am in
love with a girl and yet I can't do the
thing and they're like because you
remember the era where essentially Bill
Murray's early comedies established
every other comedy that was written yes
they were all kind of like variations of
stripes or meatballs or something like
that and there were a million guys that
look like we all looked more or less the
same and we're all hapless heroes in
these kind of like not low budget but
medium budget comedies and some of them
worked really well and by
large they were kind of like cannon
fodder for the distribution machine and
by that time I was like 36 years old and
I just said you know this you make a
sort of movie in your 20s and early 30s
and you just can't you have you got to
stop doing right and so I sat down with
my crack team of show business expert
and he said what do you think I said you
know I'm 36 and I just I just I think I
got to stop playing [ __ ] and really
was about playing men instead of boys
men who understood bitter compromise and
the next the next movie that came out of
it I think was what we started working
on Apollo 13 I you know not long after
that Apollo 30 and I think I made a
Sleepless in Seattle after that and you
know you got a gig oh yeah you got to
hit it to the point where you say all
right all right got it got a stress you
gotta gotta learn how to say no which is
a very hard thing to say it is it's a
very very hard thing to say it's so easy
to say yes to something no it's great
they're gonna pay and every time you say
I'll and you know you know I'm gonna get
to do I'm going to hit the trifecta on
this I get to play baseball shoot a gun
and kiss a girl I get to do all the
three things that you want to do in a
movie yeah so yes yes I'm dead it's hard
to say no you had to say at the end of
the day I don't know what to bring to
this I was lucky in that I was studying
theater when I was in college
University and I got a job before I got
out of college it wasn't really a job it
was just an offer to work in classical
Repertory Theatre in which the pay was
going to be the professional experience
it went along with it and there was
there was a group of us we all went and
we knew we would be gone for four or
five months we knew we would have
something to do with either five or six
productions that were in repertory and
just the activity was enough to to
warrant going I had no I had no
preconceived notions of anything I had
you know saved up enough money and to
barely survive and something would
happen and it just so happened that the
going actually was the most important
aspect of it because I went and after I
was there there was one particular show
that needed a bigger cast than the
professionals could the pressure company
could could supply and because I was
there and I ended up getting actually
paid $50 a week which was the difference
between life and death so um I I always
felt as though there was something on
the horizon that would come down the
pike that would get me through the next
the next few months but as far as you
know as far as you know bonafide break
goes the only things you can go on is
your faith and and and your instinct and
that that window of cushion that you
give you that you would be able to give
yourself you know enough money literally
to pay your rent I was married and I had
a kid at the time and just always needed
to have I say well I got 800 bucks in
the bank I think I'm good for about
another three months it's always a
battle against self consciousness it's
hard to get past that the the
realization that you're pretending to be
somebody and people are looking at you
even if it's the crew I wish I had had I
wish I had more basic things at more
tool that was had gone through more
classes I wish I had been forced to take
a dance class I wish I had forced to get
up and sing in front of people I wish I
had taken like MA I wish I'd gone to
that kind of like performance school in
which you have to get past the
self-consciousness of not being able to
do it well and still having to do it you
know what I mean it's like I I couldn't
I'd the idea of singing in front of
anybody makes my throat constrict yes I
can do it and I and I wish that I would
have thought until you weren't very good
at some point you never got beyond that
yeah yeah or get off the stage or you
don't get the job or anything like I
wish I had gone through more of the the
tools of the actor so to speak
why it took so long to get you on the
boards of Broadway with lucky men Nora
Ephron's was this past was it April May
I the great thing about the great lake
chase because Vincent Dowling said to
all of us who were interns he says
the most part I cannot pay you any money
I don't have it but I can give you
something more precious than a paycheck
and that is professional experience
working in the theatre with professional
actors and he was absolutely right
because most of the actors were from New
York there was there was a contingent
from Minneapolis a big contingent from
Kansas City where where Vincent had
worked and a bunch of us came not from
California but we were all interns and
but the lion's share of them were were
guys from New York and many of them were
gay
sure who just said look if you want to
be a professional actor there's only one
place for you to be have you're going to
do you're going to do Shakespeare for a
living you have to come to New York
where you can audition for something
that might give you a paycheck three or
four times a week you can't audition for
something three or four times a week in
Minneapolis or good and there's no
reason to go to Los Angeles because
you'll just disappear right and two
years after the end of the second year
that I was there because my son was born
in between the mic of my son Colin was
born so I went back and had that
fabulous thing happened and they didn't
you had to move on and they were right
and if they've if those wonderful people
hadn't like taken me under their wing
and said here's how you have a card in
your wallet that says you're a
professional actor now so here's what
you have to do and I end up moving here
and the reason I did not do any plays on
Broadway is because no one would hire me
to do plays on Broadway that was just
there was just nothing happening early
American naval commander John Paul Jones
said if fear is cultivated it will
become stronger if faith is cultivated
it will achieve mastery and this is why
I am a big fan of history because
observations in the American colonies
over 200 years ago by camp a tree
Nathan Hale who lived in that building
right over there
translate there you go translate
word-for-word of the United States in
2011 for I take that fear to be fear in
the large-scale fear itself intimidating
and constant and I take faith to be what
we hold in ourselves our American ideal
of self-determination fear is whispered
in our ears and shout in our faces faith
must be fostered by the man or woman you
see every day in the mirror
the former forever snaps at our heels
and our sign APS's and delays our course
the latter can spur our boot heels to be
wandering stimulate our creativity and
drive us forward fear or faith which
will be our master three men found that
they could no longer sleep because of
their deep-seated fears this is a story
I'm telling their lives were in a state
of status because of their constant
worries so they set out on a pilgrimage
to find a wise man who lived high in the
mountain so high up above the treeline
that no vegetation grew no animals live
not even insects could be found so high
up in the mountains in that thin air and
when they reached his cave the first of
the three said help me wise man for my
fear has crippled me what is your fear
said asked the wise man I fear death
said the pilgrim I wonder when it is
going to come for me ah death said the
wise man let me take away this fear my
friend death will not come to call until
you are ready for its embrace know that
and you fear will go away well this
combat pilgrims mind and he feared death
no longer
the wise banter to the second pilgrim
and said what is it you fear my friend I
fear my new neighbors said the second
pilgrim they are stranger so observe
Holy Days different than mine they have
way too many kids and they play music
that sounds like noise ah strangers said
the wise man I will take away this fear
my friend return to your home and make a
cake for your new neighbors bring toys
to their children join them in their
songs and learn their ways and you will
become familiar with these neighbors and
your fear will go away well the second
man saw the wisdom in these simple
instructions and knew he would no longer
fear the family who were his neighbors
there in the cave so high in the
mountains that nothing could live the
wise man turned the last pilgrim and
asked of his fear a wise man I fear
spiders
when I try to sleep at night
I imagine spiders dropping from the
ceiling and crawling upon my flesh and I
cannot rest ah
spiders said the wise man no she why do
you think I live way up here
fear will get the worst of the best of
us and peddler's or influence count on
that on commencement day speech makers
are expected to offer advice as though
you need any as though anything said
today could aid your making sense of our
one damn thing after another world but
things are too confused too loud too
dangerous to make advice an option you
need to hear something much more
relevant on this day you need to hear
the most important message thus far and
the third millennium you need to hear a
maxim so simple so clear and so
evocative that no one could misconstrue
its meaning or miss its weighty issue so
here goes it's not a statement it's but
it's a request it's not a bit of advice
but it's a plea in fact it's a single
four-letter word it's a verb and a noun
which takes into account the reality of
your four years advance or as well as
the demands of the next four decades you
spend beyond this campus it's a message
once made familiar by the Beatles those
northern English lads who embodied the
power of four
help
hell we need help your help you must
help please help please provide help
please be willing to help help and you
will make a huge impact on the life of
the street the town the country and our
planet if only one out of four of each
hundred of you choose to help on any
given day in any given cause incredible
things will happen in the world you live
in
help publicly help privately help in
your actions by recycling and conserving
and protecting but help also in your
attitude help make sense where sense has
gone missing help bring a reason and
respect to discourse and debate help
science to solve and faith to soothe
help law bring justice until justice is
commonplace help and you will abolish
apathy the void which is so quickly
filled by ignorance and evil life
outside of college is just like life in
it one nutty thing after another
some of them horrible but all
interspersed with enough beauty and
goodness to keep you going that's your
job to keep going your duty is to help
without ceasing the art you create can
glorify it the science you pursue can
prove its
value the law you practice can pass on
its benefits the faith you embrace will
make it the earthly manifestation of
your God here at Vassar whatever your
discipline whatever your passion you
have already experienced the exhausting
reality that there is always something
going on and there is always something
to do and most assuredly you have sensed
how effective and empowering it can be
when more than four out of 100 make the
same choice to help you will always be
able to help so do it
make peace where it is precious help
plant trees help embrace diversity and
celebrate differences help stop gridlock
in other words help solve every problem
we face every single one of them with
the power of four out of a hundred help
and we will save the world if we don't
help it won't get done
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Xavier gravel
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me in a
profile next leave in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the 10
rules have the biggest impact on you and
why what change you're going to make in
your life or business as a result of
watching this video leave in the
comments and I will join in the
discussion finally 1 think of a quick
shadow to Marcus Hahnemann Marcus thank
you so much for buying a copy of my book
it really means a lot to me those you're
watching if you want to change that a
shadow in the future video make sure to
pick up a copy of the book and email in
your receipt so we can keep track thank
you guys so much for watching
you tend to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon
go what's just so purpose in this army
to do whatever you tell my drill
sergeant
goddammit gum you're goddamn genius
that's the most outstanding answer I've
ever heard you must have a goddamn IQ of
160 you are goddamn gifted private Gump
listen up people
now for some reason I fit from the Army
like one of them round pegs not really
hard you just make your bed real neat
remember to stand up straight and always
answer every question with yes drill
sergeant what you do is you just drag
units along the muck on a good day you
catch over 100 pounds of shrimp
everything goes all right two minutes
rump in ten hours let's put you scams on
there tundra sergeant go why did you put
that weapon together so quickly go you
tell me dude you're sorry
jesus H Christ this is a new company
record if it wouldn't be a waste of such
a damn fine enlisted men I'd recommend
you for OCS private gum you are going to
be a general someday go now this is
double your weapon and continue anyway
like I was saying shrimp is the fruit of
the sea you can low the cue it boil it
broil it bake it
saute it lays on shrimp kabobs shrimp
creole gumbo and fry deep-fried stir fry
is pineapple shrimp lemon shrimp coconut
shrimp pepper shrimp shrimp soup shrimp
stew shrimp salad shrimp and potatoes
shrimp burger shrimp sandwich
that's best Baldy when you pull on me up
to right now what's it up to but wait is
it the $300 event 300 I'm a school
teacher I teach English Composition this
little town called Adly Pennsylvania
last 11 years I've been in Thomas Alva
Edison High School how's it coach the
baseball team in the spring time
be turned on
back home and I tell people what I do
for a living they think well now that
figures but over here it's a big big
mystery
so I guess I've changed some sometimes I
wonder if I've changed so much my wife
is even going to recognize me whenever
it is I get back to her and how I'll
ever be able to
to tell her about days like today
ah Ryan I don't know anything about Ryan
I don't care man means nothing to me
it's just a name but if you know if
going to Rimmel and finding him so he
can go home if that earns me the right
to get back to my wife well then then
that's my mission
I'm gonna leave I'm gonna go off and
like the war
all right all right I won't stop you
I'll even put in the paperwork
just know that every man I kill the
farther away from home I feel Captain
Phillips please coming have a seat
Thomas you I'm chief O'Brien I'll be
your corpsman today okay can you please
tell me what's going on
can you talk can you tell me what's
going on I'm okay
are you okay can you don't look okay are
you in any pain right now are you in any
pain right now right there on your side
okay let me see it really quick can you
lift up your arm a little bit
does that hurt a little bit okay is it
tender go ahead and put your arm down
okay I need you to look at me I need you
to calm down I need you to breathe there
you go
deep breaths there you go very good
awesome now I want you to relax your arm
okay we're gonna put this little thing
on your finger and we're gonna get your
heart rate and your oxygen level make
sure you're breathing okay okay I want
you to keep doing that okay what
happened to your head captain can you
tell me what happened to your head don't
you Oh God
they
okay take your time take your time
there's a two centimeter laceration on
the left eyebrow
it's okay okay okay I want you to look
at me and I want you to breathe
do you understand okay all right is that
a four centimeter gap little laceration
there on the left temple
you're doing great okay with all this
blood come from your eyebrow in your
head
come from your eyebrow right here I know
on your head okay that's not mine
right alright look at me okay we're
gonna lay you down okay yeah all right
yeah
julinho nice and gently nice and gently
uh you're okay I got you
got the near safe now okay thank you
you're welcome
you know pastor you
my family know your family knows you're
safe
you're taken care of
sir I need you to breathe
the other